I mean I have no idea what happens at
prom but do I get a limo you have to
have a limo right Rob you have a limo
you have to literally go in a helicopter
how old is he ah prom memories am i
right
I'm so grown for that Khloe Kardashian
sat out the high school tradition when
she was a kid I've never been a prom
before but I have always wondered what
prom is like and now she's getting to
experience the rite of passage for the
first time with the whole world watching
it's not crazy and she's so confused how
old is he
let's rewind in a sneak peek at the
upcoming episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Chloe reveals that a Kardashian mega fan
invited her to his dance I've developed
a relations in our Bay and naar Bay has
been a Kardashian supporter for ever and
ever he's Armenian so we share that
connection one day I think he deemed me
and asked if I would go to prom with him
and I felt you know it was a really
special request I've never been to
problems but I felt I felt really lucky
that I was invited I think that the most
important thing that a mom can ask for
is just to raise kids who are good
people and have good hearts and know
what it's like to do for someone else
and give back naturally Kris Jenner
chimed in with some unsolicited advice
for her daughter can you get champagne
no promise in high school along high
schools under 21
you're like a tweeter 34 stop rubbing it
in are you saying I can't go to prom no
you can go to prom but you can drink
that's ridiculous
in June Chloe documented her first prom
experience on Twitter posting these
shots and writing quote my very first
prom and I went with the best date ever
we had so much fun so he should buy you
a corsage I think we got these and they
need to get her a boutonniere okay got
it
gnar BAE who runs Kardashian fan
accounts on Twitter and Instagram also
shared pics of himself and Chloe in
their matching black attire alongside
the caption I'm
feeling over the moon as for that
photobomb prop reading open bar NARR Bay
explained the sign is a joke it's a high
school prom there would never be an open
bar get champagne no promise in high
school along
[Music]